sorry there's different types of men and
women like i think some men what if a
guy does want to just maybe play a more
feminine role as in like stay at home
while the woman goes out to provide like
there shouldn't be anything wrong with
that and that like vice versa like i
don't know i just don't think i think i
think men like respect and i think men
that want respect
understand that women generally if they
are doing the whole house husband thing
aren't going to be as respected as a man
who's not you know i'm saying i'm not
saying that it's wrong any man that
chooses to do that good luck buddy you
go ahead and do it but i'm just saying
men generally like the respect aspect of
a relationship a man can be respected in
a relationship because a man knows if he
gains a woman's respect she's not going
to go out elsewhere once a woman loses
respect for a man she's gone
do you know what i mean and i'm talking
about mentally and emotionally but is it
more for a man to go out and provide is
that more of a male ego or is that
because that is really what they just
think what a woman wants i think that's
the way societies have always been built
and societies get built by men that go
out and do things societies don't get
built by men that are feminine